Wow
I suppose that I'm an artist my front
yard is a revolving heart exhibit of
different pieces I have a company called
topiary Joe I make sculptures out of
steel topiary is shaping any shrubbery
or vines into a recognizable form my
first interaction with topiaries was at
Disney World I saw all the topiary forms
that were being made there and decided
that if I was going to make this
business and do it well I better be
flippin good at it one of the
requirements is I got to have a welder
you got to add music and then I can
build
I utilize this small model right here
I'll scale it out and make it look like
it's supposed to the design process
there goes from that to me getting out
the spray can and tag in my driveway or
tagging the road so that I can see
exactly what the piece is going to look
like after welding the frames together
we'll place the Spagna moth inside of
the frame then wrap it with 50-pound
fishing lines so that it doesn't come
out and then we'll plant the plants
right into the body small monkeys
they're like you know four or five
hundred dollars something like that
this one we're selling for twenty four
thousand cost-wise
you know it's the labor of doing the
steel work but there's a hell of a lot
of creativity going in that and I charge
for that
we've been doing this stuff for like 21
years now created over probably 4,000 or
so sculptures companies that we've done
work for including Google DreamWorks
Dasani was good I'm doing a really
really interesting project in San Diego
right now where customers said wow I've
got a brand new estate I need to fill it
up the customer and his daughter and I
walked the property and little girl
rules man so yeah we get a unicorn I
have spent thousands of hours in front
of a welder zapping stuff and trying to
make it look recognizable so that people
can actually smile that's that's the
purpose of all this I like to see kids
smile
you